8 septembre 2009 le détenu le plus
célèbre de France Jean-Pierre treber
s'évade de la maison d'arrêt d'Auxerre 6
mois avant de passer aux assises pour le
double meurtre de Katia herbier
Géraldine Giraud le carton dans lequel
il était caché n'avait pas de fond et
Jean-Pierre treber a donc pu s'enfuir
discrètement
voici le semi remorque à bord duquel
Jean-Pierre treber s'est évadé de la
prison pendant 3 mois il nargue les
policiers du fond de la forêt de bonbons
près de Melun les lignées de la police
sont assez trou c'est toute la presse
s'emmêle des images du fugitif tirées
d'une caméra de surveillance de la
police atterrissent même dans les
journaux
tout le monde a son avis sur la question
et la France entière se passionne pour
savoir combien de temps va durer la
folle cavale c'est ce moment là le
moment
de démarrage de la cavale qui qui donne
qui donne ce souffle romantique à la
cavale ensuite derrière
le 20 novembre fin de partie l'homme des
bois est arrêté chez la fille d'un ami
et puis le 20 février 2010 l'ultime
fuite Jean-Pierre Trabert se pend dans
sa cellule il ne sera jamais jugé
sa cavale Express a relancé le mythe les
fugitifs fascinent
[Musique]
imaginez un homme une femme qui a largué
les amarres et fit la 200 à l'heure dans
la nuit le feu aux fesses avec juste
quelques billes en poche pas de maison
juste une plante et quelques amis et
encore quand il vous voit ils ont peur
alors c'est la fuite vers une autre
plante un autre contact en évitant de se
faire remarquer pas de bagages pas de
conversation inutile pas d'histoire
peut-être un truand qui montre des coups
un évadé de prison qui a absolument
besoin d'argent
ou encore un escroc qui vient de se
faire condamner et ne s'est pas
présenter à l'audience
il ne reviendront plus chez eux c'est
trop risqué la police les attentes
[Musique]
où vont-ils combien de temps peuvent-ils
rester clandestin auront-ils assez
d'argent assez de complices auront-ils
assez de chance
[Musique]
Noël Besse sœur de François Besse le
lieutenant de Mérine femme de braqueurs
et braqueuse à ses heures pendant 8 ans
elle enchaîne évasion cavale prison
[Musique]
Laurent fioconi 69 ans aventurier et
duracuir pilier de la French Connection
il a disparu de la circulation pendant
16 ans en Amérique du Sud
Laurence charrette et pousse Segura une
gamine qui n'a pas froid aux yeux
à 18 ans elle craque pour Dédé un jeune
voyou de 24 ans une vie d'amour et de
fuite avec partout la police
[Musique]
et puis il y a les renards de la bnrf la
brigade très spéciale chargée de traquer
les fugitifs de France et de Navarre
comment font-ils pour retrouver ses
évadés ses bras cœur qui ont disparu
dans la nature depuis des années quels
sont leurs armes et leurs techniques
plongez dans les eaux profondes de la
cavale
[Musique]
Noël Besse jusqu'à l'âge de 33 ans elle
est inconnue du grand public mais pas
des policiers elle est la sœur de
François Besse le roi de l'évasion le 12
mars 1979 le lieutenant de Meryn se fait
encore la belle cette fois c'est du
Palais de Justice de Bruxelles en plein
procès un complice sa scotché des armes
sous le banc des accusés très vite les
policiers français la soupçonne d'avoir
fait le voyage en Belgique alors elle se
réfugie dans le sud elle est mise sous
surveillance
nous sommes à Saleilles un petit village
catalan et j'ai quitté cognac parce que
j'avais été en garde à vue plusieurs
fois par rapport à l'affaire de
Bruxelles l'évasion de François et donc
je suis venu me réfugier dans le sud
pensant à être à l'abri un samedi soir
il y a une bagarre et là on m'a reconnu
la PJ de Perpignan le lendemain nous
chercher ils m'ont emmené en pyjama là
ça a été le début de la cavale parce que
là je fais 72 heures de garde à vue à la
PJ de Perpignan et là je décide que
cette histoire de Bruxelles à base
régler avec ou sans moi mais moi je
quitte la France
direction l'Espagne entre temps son
frère si elle fait arrêter
[Musique]
alors Noël lui rend visite en prison et
là c'est le coup de foudre pour un de
ses codes tenues espagnoles il s'appelle
Eric et c'est un braqueur chevronné
notre rencontre a été un coup de foudre
c'est c'était
au-delà du réel c'était tellement beau
elle ne pense plus qu'à lui deux mois
plus tard le bel Hidalgo a une
permission de sortie d'une semaine
lorsque il sort on a 7 jours pour pour
poser la question à savoir si s'il va
voir le courage de rentrer et
je pense qu'on sans même en parler dans
nos yeux on voyait très clairement que
l'attirance était elle
que
c'était pas envisageable de retourner en
prison un coup de foudre dans un parloir
de prison et la vie de Noël baisse
bascule
laurent SEGURA elle aussi va céder au
charme d'un braqueur mais elle ne sait
pas acquis elle a affaire André est un
jeune ni moi fou de moto qui dit
travaillait dans l'informatique il lui
fait la cour assidûment depuis des
semaines mais Laurence résiste
quand elle cède à ses avances il est
trop tard et sa vie s'emballe
matin il est parti bon il me disait je
suis dans l'électronique enfin VRP dans
l'électronique sa salade qui m'avait
raconté mais je voyais bien qu'il y
avait des trucs qui clochait pas quoi
s'accrochait pas et
puis après j'ai entendu un tas de
sirènes
[Musique]
un bois de fou et donc je me suis mis à
mon balcon et en bas de des appartements
il y avait une Caisse d'Epargne et en
partant et ben il avait décidé
avec un pote à lui de
braquer là Caisse d'Épargne où j'avais
mon petit compte en banque parce que
j'étais pas riche où j'avais mon compte
en banque en bas après il est revenu me
chercher mais bon
là là j'ai mis le pied dedans quoi
[Musique]
monter derrière lui sur la moto il est
venu me chercher et là il s'est dit
c'est celle-là je la veux et il m'a eu
quoi et donc je suis monté derrière lui
on est parti sur les grands chemins
et on a été loin
un voyou qui a été loin très loin c'est
Laurent fioconi c'est qu'il a été élevé
par un parrain de haute volée son oncle
judithelli très vite le petit Laurent
travaille son CV de bandicore maison de
correction proxénétisme escroquerie et
braquage avec le vent nouveau de 68 il
se met au trafic d'héroïne c'est la
French Connection et la connexion pour
vendre l'héroïne de Marseille à la mafia
New Yorkais c'est lui qui l'a
mais toutes les bonnes choses ont une
fin et en 71 il est extradé avec son
complice Jean-Claude Kella vers les
États-Unis puis condamné à 25 ans de
prison
[Musique]
il y reste trois ans et en 74 il s'évade
avec ses complices italiens du
pénitencier d'Atlanta
on avait une voiture que nous attendait
en face avec les clés sur le paillasson
on avait un appartement qu'on avait loué
on avait tout préparé et on s'est mis
dans un appartement pendant trois mois
mais après comme on a vu qu'on était un
peu découvert et tout on a voulu changer
d'appartement et on s'est séparé des
Italiens parce qu'ils étaient toujours
ils sortaient tous les jours direction
Miami où les attend un avion privé plan
de vol la Colombie sans passer par la
case passeport
on est arrivé un peu tard donc on a fait
semblant d'être en détresse et on a on
atterri à Carthagène normalement on
avait
vous intéresser toujours avec le vent de
face et en faisant ça on avait on
arrivait devant
les policiers tout ça donc on a atterri
à sens contraire scandale avec la tour
de contrôle et tout ça nous on a pu se
jeter au en bout de piste
une zone où nous sommes partis faire la
nuit dans Carthagène et tout seul toute
la nuit et à la fin on est comme on
n'avait pas de chambre on a dormi dans
un bordel il y avait claqué
et le lendemain matin à la terrasse d'un
grand hôtel le rang fioconi rencontre
Nina elle ne sait pas qu'il vient de
s'évader et d'atterrir clandestinement
en Colombie et on était un endroit où il
y avait des filles elles étaient là
elles arrivaient sortaient tout ça et
elle est arrivée avec des copines je
crois d'autres copines et donc on les
invités si vous voulez s'asseoir avec
nous et tout ça donc des étrangers vous
pensez de suite ce sont ainsi et comme
il y a pas de pages j'ai dit venez vous
asseoir sur mes genoux s'asseoir sur mes
genoux et de fil en aiguille on est
resté on est resté ensemble
mais mais qu'est-ce qu'elle fait c'est
pas 200 là elle m'a pris pour
Jésus-Christ
j'avais 33 ans la barbe et elle a dit ça
c'est Jésus-Christ
Nina Laurence et Noël n'ont pas pu
résister aux charmes du bandit de grand
chemin
le voyou c'est quelqu'un qui qui fait
rêver un certain nombre de personnes
parce que finalement dans sa vie il va
obtenir tout ce que l'homme ordinaire
entre guillemets obtiendra jamais il va
refuser tous les carcans qui sont ceux
qui enferment quelque part la vie
ordinaire de
l'homme qui va bon avoir un certain
nombre de règles d'habitude donc quelque
part il symbolise cette espèce de même
si c'est pas une vraie liberté mais la
liberté et effectivement je crois que
c'est c'est pour cette raison là qui
qu'il fait qu'il fait rêver parce qu'il
a brisé quelque part il a refusé les
patrons il a refusé les horaires il a
refusé de se plier même au jour et à la
nuit il vit la nuit il vit bon tout ce
qui peut enfermer la vie finalement dans
des dans des habitudes
regardez la télé de telle heure à telle
heure prendre le métro tous les matins à
telle heure etc il refuse
Noël Besse et Eric
Laurence et André Segura
Laurent fioconi et Nina trois couples en
fuite qui ont tout partagé les bons
moments les vols les galères et ceux qui
les a soudés bien sûr c'est la peur on
se relayé pour dormir deux heures lui
deux heures roulement de
pour se reposer mais c'est même pas du
repos on se lève le matin on est on est
fatigué alors on prend des vitamines
dans mon cas c'est la vitamine pour mon
mari c'est des produits plus forts déjà
on est tendus on est paranoïa qu'on est
on est plus que paranoïaque si s'il
existe un terme on a l'adrénaline
décompose le pied le matin du lit
on est on est à la limite de la transe
parce qu'on se sait poursuivi tu deviens
complètement parano le soir Arthur tu
tiens un appartement tu vis dans un
appart tu fais autour du bâtiment
tu vois une voiture avec deux trois mecs
louches après tu apprends à repérer les
oui quelqu'un d'étrange vous voyez même
un policier ou un truc comme ça vous
devenez tout vous commencez à être en
position pour n'importe quoi et vous il
y a la trading qui vous vient même un
peu la peur un peu plein d'effets vous
analysez vous êtes vous êtes à 100% sur
le TV jour nuit c'est très c'est très
fatigant mais c'est bien ça vous apprend
à un peu à
vivre
il faut là il faisait il faut se
débrouiller tout seul
stress angoisse coup de chaud la cavale
est une succession d'accélération et de
doute la principale difficulté se
trouvait une bonne plante la plante est
une maison en principe isolée dans la
campagne nous situe au bord de la mer
donc assez relativement facile à louer
dans une agence tout simplement mais ne
pas y rester plus de deux semaines trois
semaines c'est le grand maximum
tous les deux trois mois un ou deux ou
de maison et quand je voyais un truc
touche de suite je j'avais toujours une
maison ou un appartement de
en retrait pour pouvoir partir et des
chaque fois j'en avais un et j'avais un
autre que c'était mon en cas de pépin je
savais où aller et après toujours comme
ça ça a toujours été comme ça on a vécu
pendant 16 ans comme ça pour prendre le
minimum de risque il faut avoir au moins
deux ou trois appartements il faut avoir
des garages il faut avoir plusieurs
véhicules
ça coûte tout ça voilà vivre en cavale
ça coûte 10 15 20 fois plus cher que de
vivre
de manière officielle etc parce que et
en plus plus vous êtes recherché plus
vous êtes entre guillemets chaud plus
vous avez la police aux fesses plus vous
plus ça va vous coûter cher parce que
plus les gens qui vont vous vendre des
faux papiers vont vous les vendre cher
plus les gens qui vont accepter de vous
soulever des appartements pour vous
demander d’argent plus les gens qui vont
vous transporter vont vous taxer et donc
le principal problème c'est celui de
l'argent
pour trouver de l'argent pour financer
leur cavale Noël baisse et son mari Eric
vont écumer pendant un an et demi les
banques de la Costa Brava une côte que
son mari connaît bien et là mon mari
avait fait toutes ces petites banques là
ils connaissaient tout tout ce chemin
alors donc on s'arrête dans des villas
on reste une semaine de semaine bon par
après on continue on continue on
s'arrête à Tarragone parce que Tarragone
on
rate un gros coup ça se passe très mal
deux doigts de se faire arrêter donc
dégoûté on décide de redescendre par les
terres là on arrive sur Benidorm parce
que là c'est la dernière qu'on décide
que c'est la dernière là on la travaille
énormément et c'est c'est la bonne
catastrophe c'est là
tourne mal la cavale de Noël Bay ça
failli se terminer à Benidorm en entrant
dans l'agence un client donne l'alerte
Eric et piéger dans le sas et Noël doit
faire exploser cloison en verre pour le
délivrer il semblait c'est mais arrive à
regagner leur planque
pour vivre à l'abri en Colombie Laurent
Fiocconi mais sur pied de nouveaux
trafic il s'associe un temps avec des
guerriers-roses du M19 ordre est alors
donné de l'exécuter il part se cacher
dans la jungle un des meilleurs moments
que j'ai passé c'est les moments que
j'ai passé dans la jungle
c'est des moments très forts et en plus
c'était c'est magnifique je vivais
j'avais une maison juste en face d'une
cascade de trois étages et ça avait avec
un grand lac parce que la cascade est
tombée et ça il y avait un lac immense
avec la plage autour et tout et moi
j'avais juste la maison juste en face si
les réflexes de caïd et ses complices
protègent fianconi il a aussi trouvé un
bon filon pour financer sa cavale
transformer les feuilles de coca en
cocaïne donc je sais que ici ça choque
plus ou moins ça choque énormément mais
là-bas ça choque pas tout le monde
travaille
sinon il perd tout le monde
ils auraient pas pour manger donc tout
le monde fait ça donc le commissaire à
Sacha il s'appelle les champs là-bas ils
appellent ça des chakras comme il sert à
Sacha que le juge à Sacha le policier à
Sacha qu'on a fermé à chaque tout le
monde tout le monde tout le monde fait
cultive ça donc je me suis familiarisé
là-bas et comme je m'ennuyais il y a pas
de télévision il y avait pas de radio il
y avait rien donc j'aimais me
spécialiser j'ai des je me je
m'entraînais je regardais chez comment
comment il faisait les Indiens et tout
ça et il y a peut-être au fil des 18 je
suis réveillé à être pas trop mauvais
dans dans ça et ça m'a permis de
survivre pendant 3 ans Laurent va vivre
dans la jungle colombienne sans eau sans
électricité avec toujours un pistolet à
portée de main à ses côtés sa femme et
de tout jeunes enfants un bébé en cavale
le risque maximum pour un fugitif
[Musique]
1984 Benidorm en Espagne Noël Besse qui
vient d'écumer les banques de la Costa
Brava avec son mari est enceinte voilà
j'étais enceinte à Benidorm donc je
viens accoucher ici à Alicante clinique
privée paiement en liquide Noël baisse
ne prend aucun risque dès le lendemain
de son accouchement à l'aube elle file à
l'anglaise
la petite diamètre on décide de se
mettre au vert donc là on descend et on
descend jusqu'à Murcia ici
mais Noël se rend compte que sa fille
n'a pas de papier officiel contre la vie
de son mari elle décide d'aller à la
mairie d'Alicante pour déclarer sa fille
une formalité qu'elle prépare
soigneusement comme un braquage
on avait fait des repérages d'abord déjà
de savoir où trouver la mairie comment
il allait se positionner pour m'attendre
devant la porte
en cas qu'on me reconnaisse parce que là
j'étais recherchée quand même lui reste
donc dans la voiture et moi je fais la
queue parce qu'il y avait du monde avant
moi donc j'essaie de passer mais c'était
pas possible on poussait et j'avais
l'enfant dans les bras j'avais pas
laissé la petite dans la voiture j'avais
mon enfant dans les bras donc là il a
fallu quand même que je sorte mes
papiers d'identité les vrais c'était
très risqué et je me suis ressorti avec
l'acte avec le livret de famille avec
mon nom mon prénom mon lieu de naissance
le lieu de naissance de l'enfant son nom
son prénom si j'avais pas reconnu cet
enfant on pouvait m'accuser de l'avoir
volé donc j'avais il me fallait un
papier authentique deux mois après le
couple est arrêté la police a repéré une
voiture utilisée lors d'un braquage et
les remontent facilement Noël est
incarcéré heureusement elle a le livret
de famille et peut garder sa fille avec
elle elle resteront un an en prison à
Madrid
[Musique]
1986 Laurence Ségura à son tour est
enceinte elle n'est pas impliquée dans
les braquages de son mari alors elle
rentre à Nîmes pour accoucher André est
toujours en cavale Laurence et Michou
surveillance
pour accoucher j'ai des policiers qui
qui faisaient des allées venus dans ma
dans ma chambre parce que André m'avait
envoyé un bouquet de roses
et donc ils ont dû savoir que j'avais eu
le contact et ils se sont dit il va
péter un câble il va craquer il va venir
voir son enfant c'est pas possible mais
de toute façon on a le doute ils étaient
obligés de faire leur boulot quoi donc
ça allait venir on savait jamais si
c'était un tout bien infirmier ou je
m'en foutais quoi je faisais pas trop
attention mais je m'en suis réellement
aperçue quand mon mon quand mon mon to
be qui m'avait accouché a pété un câble
et les aviraient quoi il leur a dit
maintenant ça suffit vous faites votre
boulot mais moi je fais le mien elle a
eu un accouchement très difficile
maintenant vous vous dégagez de là
sachiez quoi
son boulot
tout de suite après l'accouchement
Laurence la plus qu'une obsession
retrouvée André qui se cache
[Musique]
les boules de pain après ça me voilà je
sais pas comment expliquer ça mais ça me
donc j'avais fait déjà par intermédiaire
que c'était terminé entre nous que je ne
voulais catégoriquement plus le voir que
qui fasse sa vie que j'allais faire la
mienne avec avec mon enfant et que
c'était ma fille là quand il a su ça
l'art appliquer ses fesses et
en fait c'est le fils de d'un ami d'un
ami à nous qui est venu un gamin de 11
ans qui est venu me récupérer j'ai pris
le bébé sous le bras bien entendu j'ai
pas réfléchi de secondes et demi j'ai eu
un volupé mon bébé dans la couverture
j'étais je crois un habit de maison tout
pourri avec des tâches de javel et je me
suis partie comme ça et j'ai tout laissé
grâce à ce gamin on voyait par André
Laurence peut fausser compagnie au
policiers qui la surveille et le
rejoindre dans sa planque
on se retrouve dans un appartement à
Alès et donc j'arrive avec le petit
paquet j'avais la couverture et tout et
quand je l'ai vu j'avais toujours les
boules quand même de pas l'avoir vu
depuis quelques temps et j'ai le paquet
le bébé et
elle bougeais pas le dormait faisait que
dormir manger donc c'est un paquet quoi
et je lui ai mis je dis tiens
ta fille
la petite famille passe alors la
frontière pendant 7 ans ils vont
sillonner l'Espagne l'Italie la Belgique
la Suisse une vie de famille presque
normale donc un on a profité un peu de
l'Espagne on avait loué en été carrément
Aller en bas à Malaga on avait loué une
maison qui donnait direct sur la plage
et on vivait tranquillement
on avait renouveau un appartement
au bord de la mer ou c'était tranquille
mais bon on a toujours le souci
se dire
si on est pas repéré par repérer
selon si on a des bons papiers pas des
bons papiers des convois et képis que ce
soit en France ou ailleurs
les fesses on n'est pas dans une stagne
quoi on a l'impression de stagner un peu
j'avais toujours le strict minimum voilà
j'avais les petits jouets de maman ont
racheté aussi parce que bon des fois des
fois on partait un peu en catastrophe et
on laissait tout donc on est obligé de
racheter mais je me rappelle ma fille
elle a eu 11 poussettes
les voyous qui ne veulent faire courir
de risques à personne qui savent que de
toute façon
ils tombent pour ça ils vont ils vont
éviter ils vont éviter d'avoir des
enfants pendant leur cavale parce que
c'est trop voyant c'est c'est le piège
évident
malgré sa prudence de Sioux leur
enfioconi a circulé en Colombie avec sa
femme et leur deux bébés
[Musique]
quand la famille s'est réfugiée dans la
jungle Thomas le plus jeune avait trois
ans qu'on est enfant on sait pas tout à
fait ce qu'il fait pour moi c'était
plutôt un héros qui ont voyagé beaucoup
alors ça va donner beaucoup d'envies
d'être à côté de lui mais c'était le
temps où vous devez se méfier c'est le
temps il faut les faire attention à qui
comment qu'est-ce qu'on dit qu'est-ce
qu'on dit pas et c'est pas une vie
vraiment pour un enfant c'est à dire
parce que on peut pas s'exprimer comment
on veut
[Musique]
c'est l'amitié avec maman
parce que aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
vraiment des amis de 15-16 ans au plus
tôt c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui mes amis
sont un peu partout et je peux plus
prendre contact c'est à dire j'ai
presque pas la vie mais bon les amis on
les contacts
malgré les activités de son père Thomas
n'a pas pris de bal perdu
mais il est clair qu'on ne sort pas
indemne d'une enfance en cavale
allez
1 2 3
joyeux anniversaire
pour éviter des blessures trop profondes
à sa fille laurent SEGURA a inventé
mille russe pour qu'elle puisse voir son
père en cavale des rendez-vous familiaux
à l'insu de la police bien sûr
André qui a été arrêté plusieurs fois
par la police espagnole et s'est évadé
la rejoint ce 29 décembre 1994 pour
fêter les 7 ans de leur fille
[Musique]
puis Laurence rentre à Nîmes la police
ne la lâche pas d'une semaine
sortie et paf je partais en courant je
passais je passerai là aussi par en
dessous il y avait le il y avait un
espèce de petite rivière il y avait la
passerelle je passais en dessous et
claque il savait pas par où j'allais
sortir donc et obligé de les voir je les
entendais courir à la vie devant moi des
fois je me retrouvais nez à nez avec une
fois il y en avait il m'a dit il a vu
que je l'avais vu il m'a dit vas-y il
traverse en dehors des passages cloutés
parce que j'étais déjà en dehors des
passages cloutés et
ben quel patient il doit avoir quand
même les pauvres
[Musique]
c'est ce groupe de policiers du SRPJ de
Bordeaux qui suivait Laurent Ségura de
près leur idée qu'elle les met sur la
trace de la planque de son mari pendant
un an ils vont suivre ses déplacements
écoutez ses conversations téléphoniques
identifier son entourage
aujourd'hui c'est policiers sont à la
retraite mais il se souviennent très
bien de laurent SEGURA et de ses trucs
pour déjouer leur filature elle est
rentrée dans un hôtel elle est elle est
ressortie et elle est par une autre
sortie et il y a une voiture qui attend
les autres ok elle reparti voilà donc
nous on était toujours sur la voiture
qui est arrivé
non c'est pas évident parce que c'était
sans doute parmi les personnes qu'on a
qu'on a surveillé la plus retors
la plus difficile à suivre
pas dans les bars clubs tout ça c'était
pas viré
de famille qui s'occupait de ses gosses
les gosses avaient intérêt à bien
travailler à l'école tout ça quoi
c'était et elle faisait je crois qu'il y
avait un animal devait faire du
repassage des trucs comme ça avec sa
belle-sœur
[Musique]
mais surtout ça quand elle devait aller
chercher systématiquement récupérer la
gamine et puis un jour était plus là
voilà
elle partait de rejoindre des revenus
quoi 15 jours il y aura près
au bout d'un an de filature infructueuse
la police et le juge d'instruction de
l'époque à l'Arenal décide d'organiser
un grand coup de filet dans l'entourage
des Segura à l'Arenal soupçonne André
d'avoir pris l'identité de quelqu'un
d'autre ce que les policiers appellent
une doublette l'ensemble de ces éléments
nous ont simplement permis d'obtenir un
tout petit élément minuscule les deux ou
trois identités que pouvaient ou qui
étaient susceptible de d'être utilisé
par André Segura c'est tout ce que nous
avons pu avoir dans ce coup de pied de
la fourmilière mais ce petit fil
d'Ariane nous a suffi puisque en fait on
a subodoré que ces trois identités
étaient en fait ce qu'on appelle des
doublettes donc on a vérifié au travers
des fichiers nationaux de la sécurité
sociale EDF etc où se trouvait ces trois
personnes ces trois personnes tout
simplement un fonctionnaire de police
est allé tranquillement à proximité des
adresses concernées et il se trouve que
pour l'une des trois
André Segura utilisé donc l'une des
trois fausses identités à Annecy
30 avril 1997 la fausse identité d'André
Segura tombe la police l'interpelle
calmement alors qu'il rejoint sa planque
à Annecy la fin de 6 ans de cavale le
braqueur roi de l'évasion tombe parce
que quelqu'un dans son entourage a été
trop bavard
[Musique]
1986 en Espagne Noël baisse sort de
prison elle est en liberté provisoire
6 mois plus tard elle organise l'évasion
de son homme une évasion avec son lot
d'inattendu
tout se passe très bien on les
manques de sens mon mari par pas seul ça
je le savais pas il part avec deux
collègues là de et dont l'ennemi public
numéro 1 espagnol en premier lieu
il décide de ne pas aller dans la
cachette que j'avais prévu avec ce qu'il
fallait pour tenir minimum un mois pour
la petite pour moi pour lui et arriver à
murcial c'était l'apothéose c'était un
appartement dans un immeuble bon déjà on
n'avait pas la clé donc on a dû attendre
dans le parking en face c'était la ils
sont arrivés les deux côtés tenus sont
arrivés mais
ivre mort
en criant et moi en halluciné avec mon
mari on était derrière les poteaux de
parking en disant mais c'est c'est pas
possible quoi le couple réussit à
fausser compagnies à ses qualités
espagnols trop voyants pendant quelques
mois encore il repartent en cavale sans
argent à bout de souffle mon mari décide
de rentrer en France et c'était une
erreur parce que moi j'arrêtais pas de
lui dire que qu'en France j'étais
recherchée que que si on s'était pas
possible que je remette un pied en
France et lui il me traiter de parano
parano pas tout à fait la fuite de Noël
d'Éric et de leur petite fille va se
terminer par une arrestation
rocambolesque en France c'est Guy Armand
qui les interpellent en juillet 97 il
connaissait déjà Noël baisse il avait
mis en garde à vue peu après l'évasion
de François Besse du Palais de Justice
de Bruxelles 7 ans auparavant
à cette époque nous étions un petit
voyou local
qui fournissait des armes
à droite à gauche donc si vous voulez on
s'intéressait et en prenant en filature
cet homme
un jour on a eu la surprise de le voir
rencontrer un couple avec un bébé
et là j'ai reconnu Noël baisse on
continue d'en surveillance on les prend
en filature
et puis là il se rendent à Saint-Cyprien
au bord de la mer
Noël best reste avec son bébé sur la
plage
les deux hommes à ce moment-là change de
voiture monte dans un autre véhicule on
saura plus tard que c'est un véhicule
volé rentre dans une bande fond hold-up
et ressortent aussi sauts
en venant d'Espagne et nous n'avions
plus du tout d'argent donc
mon mari décide de
d'aller chercher de l'argent où il
savait le trouver c'est-à-dire
une banque cette banque en l'occurrence
on a été un peu surpris on a assisté de
loin à cette scène on les voit revenir
sur la plage bon et là bien sûr en
flagrant délire on décide de les
interpeller alors
ouais
c'est Laura coup parce que là là c'est
le port effectivement c'est la voilà
donc ils ont dû effectivement passer par
là les cowboys
c'était en plein été la plage était
bondée de monde il faisait très beau ce
jour-là et mon mari est arrivé moi je me
trouvais là avec ma petite fille de 2
ans et demi et là il me dit voilà ça y
est on a fait on a on vient de braquer
une banque à Saint-Cyprien à quelques
kilomètres d'ici et mon mari tout fier
en disant ça s'est bien passé on a eu
aucun problème et moi je le regarde
stupéfaite en lui disant mais les
problèmes ils sont derrière toi parce
qu'il y en a partout donc mon mari il a
pris le il a il a il s'est retourné
quand il a vu que tout tout ça c'était
plein de policiers il a commencé à
prendre la mer il y a un des policiers
qui s'est déshabiller parce que c'était
habillé c'est déshabiller les parties
comme un fou dans la mer en crawl et
tout et je voyais mon mari c'était
comme situation sur le moment ce joyeux
mon mari qui est peiné qui peinait bon
et le policier a réussi à le rattraper
et voilà la ramener sur la plage j'ai
pas ils se sont plus ou moins battus
dans l'eau je sais pas tu as des remous
etc et quand tu l'ont ramené sur la
plage là ils se sont jetés sur lui long
allongé sur le sable son collègue était
déjà
maîtrisé lui il avait déjà les bras
crois dans le sable et puis moi qui
essayait toujours de partir vers avec ma
fille vers le l'autre bout là-bas mais
ils m'ont rattrapé également très vite
et puis
elle me dit bon c'est fini je dis oui
c'est fini Noël donc pour la pour le
bébé on reste tranquille on bouge pas et
là je prends ma petite dans les bras il
me il prend la petite il la repose
méchamment dans dans le sable et il me
pointe un fling sur la tombe comme ça et
il me dit maintenant avant c'est fait
pas d'histoire on récupère donc le
véhicule le butin les armes et tout ça
tout ce beau monde à la PJ et voilà donc
ça se ça s'est joué là en quelques
quelques minutes en fait Noël baisse
fera 2 ans de prison
Eric son compagnon 12 il meurt quelques
années plus tard fin de l'aventure
[Musique]
la prison etc c'est bien quand on est
tout seul qu'on a pas de charge et puis
qu'on pense qu'on n'est pas aimé qu'on
s'aime pas soi-même si c'est très
délicat comme sujet mais c'est dès qu'on
donne de l'amour
à un enfant un peu plus permettre des
de risquer sa vie déjà
André Segura lui aussi a déposé les
armes en 2002 au bout de 50 prisons il
bénéficie d'une libération
conditionnelle il prend un emploi montre
son entreprise serait insère mais la
Belgique réclame un reliquat de peine et
il repart en cavale Laurence crie à
l'injustice il est finalement gracile
aujourd'hui il a retrouvé sa famille et
une vie normale les Segura ont tiré un
trait sur leur passé
[Musique]
c'est un cercle vicieux c'était brisant
évasion cavale cavale prison évasion
c'était pas possible de de c'est le
cercle infernal et ça rend fou complet
1988 Laurent fioconi tombe lui à Rio
après 16 ans de fuite les Américains
sont toujours assez trousse et son
argent ne suffit plus pour s'arranger
avec la police locale
il est mis en prison avec femme et
enfant
terminus de la cavale il avait un peu
trop baissé sa garde après des années
vous faites pas attention comme au début
avant tout tous se calculer tout se
pensait mais après ça devient une
routine si vous voulez et c'est là que
tout le monde pêche
et puis on définitive j'en avais marre
pour ma famille pour tous c'est
je crois que c'est mieux que pouvait
m'arriver
parce que j'ai quand même fait 16 ans de
cavale
les enfants ils étaient ils commencent à
grandir ma femme et tout ça
a été aussi bien de payer la dette
il faut la payer un jour
Laurent fioconi arrêté au Brésil Noël
baisse sur une plage d'Argelès
André Segura dans sa planque d'Annecy
qui sont ses spécialistes de la traque
qui ne l'a jamais le morceau
[Musique]
pour retrouver ce qui échappe à la
justice une brigade spécialisée a été
créée au sein de la police judiciaire la
brigade nationale de recherche des
fugitifs
40 policiers enquêteurs qui savent aussi
bien utiliser leur matière grise pour
que leur cycle Sawer de service leur job
s'occupait des personnes recherchées les
plus dangereuses les évadés de prison
les truands et trafiquants et les
condamnés par défaut
c'est eux qui ont arrêté Jean-Pierre
trebert ou qui ont traqué ces arrêts
baptistiques l'ancien proche des
Brigades rouges en moyenne la BNF
retrouve et interpelle une cinquantaine
de fugitifs par an leurs outils des
écoutes des indicateurs
Bobigny des fichiers spécialisés tous
les moyens de la police judiciaire si on
INFILE conducteur d'une personne que
l'on pense être en relation avec un
fugitif il faut se mettre derrière elle
il faut travailler faut voir si quand
elle sort de chez elle elle utilise pas
une cabine téléphonique si quand elle
sort de chez elle elle va pas dans un
cybercafé je ne sais pas donc tout ça
sont des moyens qui sont mis en œuvre
qui sont des moyens traditionnels
[Musique]
ce matin les hommes de Didier le chef de
groupe partent planqué en banlieue pour
des raisons de sécurité ils seront
floutés ils s'installe près du domicile
d'un roumain la justice allemande
demande son extradition en 1979 il a
tenté de braquer une bijouterie c'était
il y a plus de 30 ans mais en droit
allemand il n'y a pas de prescription
ouais Stéphane Stéphane c'est Didier tu
pourrais bouger toi te mettre côté N3 si
des fois l'objectif est annoncé toi tu
démarres tu te mets tu essayes de te
mettre ton cul on fait comme si de rien
n'était et puis on en tirer une filature
classique
ok on se découvre pas
il faut quand même des gens calmes et
pas impulsif
parce que c'est jamais quoi nous sommes
pas on fait pas du saute dessus à tour
de bas non on n'est pas là pour
on n'est pas là pour faire du chiffre si
à allemand il y a une erreur
c'est un petit contrôle tout bête
basique sans conséquence
[Musique]
il va une trentaine de notes du quartier
il rentre dans la rue
l'individu semble correspondre au
signalement
je me rapproche
le motard arrive sur place avec un
policier à pied ils prennent
l'initiative d'un contrôle d'identité
les autres suivent l'opération à la
radio au cas où
ouais j'arrive
[Musique]
il a décalé sur lui là
il y a pas de problème
contrôle positif c'est bien la personne
recherchée
l'individu était armé mais il s'est
laissé interpeller sans résistance s'il
ne peut pas justifier d'un port d'arme
les policiers vont pouvoir faire une
perquisition chez lui ce qui n'était pas
prévu au départ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les policiers restent sur leur garde la
porte peut être piégée ou un complice
caché dans l'appartement ou encore des
armes dissimulées prêtes à fonctionner
alors c'est bon
[ __ ] mais vous dormez avec un calibre
comme ça là
vous dites vous dormez avec une
mitraillette
[Musique]
une mitraillette dans le lit mais les
policiers ne sont pas au bout de leur
surprise il y a un véritable arsenal
dans le petit studio
alors ça va
pas donne-moi le numéro de série
elle est dangereuse
toutes les armes sont pas fonctionner
cartouche en vrai marteau à l'arrière je
n'ai plus qu'à appuyer sur la queue de
détente et ça part
attends
le suspect n'a pas accumulé que des
armes il y a aussi des valises avec des
caméras cachées
il y a aussi des gilets par balles et
des armes de guerre
[Musique]
dessus
adhésif que ça peut servir pour soit
lier des personnes ou les mettre sur la
bouche etc donc ça peut bon c'est
peut-être pas le profil de notre gamme
ça peut éventuellement aussi avoir servi
vu qu'il y a des Taki walkies un peu
tout ça rentre un peu dans l'équipement
du saucissonneur j'ai vu dans vos yeux
vous étiez posé la question est-ce que
je sors mon arme ou est-ce que je la
sors pas non vous êtes posés
sinon on était quoi
il me demande je sors je sors pas je me
suis pas posé la question parce que si
je me la poser
j'hésite pas vous allez prendre une
cartouche là dessus
ah bah oui
mais je sais bien je sais bien
que ça se passe bien on est
un garçon intelligent nous peut-être un
peu moins mais on va le décider de
l'aide on va essayer de l'être et puis
voilà et puis là on fait notre boulot
port d'armes non autorisée avec le
facteur aggravant d'associations de
malfaiteurs le soi-disant collectionneur
d'armes ne va pas être extradé tout de
suite vers l'Allemagne il va d'abord
répondre de ses actes devant la justice
française
il risque jusqu'à 10 ans
d'emprisonnement
[Musique]
de retour au service les hommes de
Didier procèdent un inventaire des
collègues spécialisés viennent
identifier les arbres
c'est un vérita 35 la première arme de
James Bond avant qu'on lui impose Walter
PPK dans je crois James Bond contre Dr
No c'est celui-là
de les faire parler de voir si elles ont
servi à d'autres délits dans d'autres
affaires numéro de série modification
reconditionnement autant d'indices qui
peuvent faire démarrer une nouvelle
piste 571 703 703 elle a été remontée
certainement avec deux numéros puisqu'il
y a deux numéros apparents et même ici
qui est là
mais qui me paraît bizarre
on dirait qu'il était frappé dessus
222,32 on remarque sur le gilet que le
numéro d'identification il a été il a
été découpé quoi
national pour sa défense le suspect se
dit collectionneur d'armes mais à
l'examen pour les spécialistes cet
argument ne tient pas tout à fait
d'accord avec l'idée de collectionneur
parce que je vois pas les le travail
qu'il a fait sur le ou fait faire sur le
Beretta par exemple pas un travail de
collectionneur il a bien abîmé bien
abîmé le flingue donc ce que un
collectionneur n'accepterait pas de
faire le filetage qui a été fait ici à
bouffer toute une partie de l'avant de
la culasse pour pouvoir y installer ce
silencieux là
qui s'adapte tout à fait dessus je l'ai
monté tout à l'heure
un collectionneur l'aurait pas fait
ça démontre aussi que les gens
lorsqu'ils sont en cavale et restent
actif bien en l'occurrence c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d'armes chez
lui beaucoup de munitions des gilets par
balles on va dire le parfait matériel du
braqueur ou de l'individu qui fournit
les équipes de braqueurs je dirais que
là c'est un petit peu la cerise sur le
gâteau et on est plutôt satisfait de
d'avoir agi d'avoir agi de la sorte et
d'avoir pris les précautions et d'avoir
travaillé sur cette individu pour nous
c'est plutôt une c'est plutôt une
réussite d'une affaire d'une affaire
encore une fois qui au départ est très
ancienne
je me suis jamais plié je me suis
pourtant c'était des [ __ ] marchand de
multi sur creux au-dessus
pour avoir tout ça tranquillement par
contre j'aimerais bien savoir quand
est-ce que je peux on peut m'enlever ça
attends
la fin d'une cavale c'est un moment
particulier ou un flic et un truand
arrive à se parler c'est une grande
satisfaction pour le premier un
soulagement parfois pour le deuxième
pendant quelques instants flics et voyou
par le même langage peut-être même dans
quelques années se reveront-ils comme
Jean-Marie Flory et Laurent fioconi
Jean-Marie Flory fut l'un des premiers
policiers de la brigade des stupes Miss
sur pied dans les années 70 pour
démanteler la French Connection la
filière clandestine de Laurent fioconi
il a rencontré pour la première fois en
1988 dans sa prison brésilienne peu
après son arrestation ce matin il vient
lui rendre une petite visite en voisins
vous avez
est en fait vite très dur
[Musique]
il y a des soucis
des inquiétudes sans arrêt
de ne pas se faire prendre
toutes ces longues années d'errance où
il faut se cacher ou changer l'identité
je crois je sais pas on pourrait lui on
pourra en discuter avec lui mais je sais
pas s'il regrette ou pas
[Musique]
demain il lui était donné de recommencer
sa vie si il était
décidé de recommencer le même chemin de
reprendre le même chemin je sais pas
[Musique]
où ça va Jean-Marie Fleury a quitté la
police en 1996 Laurent fioconi est
rentré dans son village en 2000 après
avoir purgé 12 ans dans une prison de
haute sécurité américaine
[Applaudissements]
on attend les partages
de convertir le diable de la maison
en 1988 le limier des stupes a fait le
voyage au Brésil pour auditionner
l'homme qu'il suivait à la trace depuis
16 ans pour la première fois il pouvait
l'interroger petit souvenir entre
retraités
on était venu le voir pour des détails
pour conforter l'enquête judiciaire mais
moi dans un coin secret de
ma mémoire de ma tête j'avais envie en
parlant avec lui de d'avoir
des précisions sur l'équipe qui recevait
la marchandise on n'était pas tout à
fait sûr de savoir qui était qui et
combien et donc j'ai essayé d'oublier le
verbe donner un petit peu mais il est
malin il ne va rien dire
voilà il a senti le petit peu le piège
quoi parce qu'on a parlé de toutes
et moi j'essaye de faire un peu pas le
bon métier mais de contrecarrer quand
même mais on peut pas j'avais un truc
d'aventurier j'aimais
monter des trucs et on était content que
c'était bien passé tout ça peut-être que
j'aurais pu serre dans autre chose aussi
mais non c'était ça a été ma vie oui
c'est j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir j'ai
perdu beaucoup de choses aussi par
exemple la famille les trucs comme ça
hein donc si j'avais refait ma vie
peut-être que je ferai ou peut-être que
je pourrais dire différemment
sans rancune l'ancien trafiquant
dédicace à l'ancien policier le livre
qu'il a écrit sur sa vie
de France avec tout mon respect et
admiration amicalement
mais qui a fini par tomber ciao comme
Noël best et son homme comme André
Segura
les cavales finissent mal en général
[Musique]